foreign
in Brooklyn hey welcome to the show
hello what's going on
what's going on ladies
um
so I we started the the baby steps about
a month and a half ago and we owe we owe
my uncle eleven thousand dollars in rent
and you know we started paying the
credit cards but I think that this
should come first
so I said this to my husband he said ask
Dave Ramsey and
and let's find out what you guys say and
here you are because he's skeptical
about it yeah for sure so how much
credit card debt do you guys have
credit cards like not like fifteen
thousand fifteen thousand okay all
together all together yeah not much we
really set that up but we had car loans
too okay and how much are those
uh 10 and 25 10 and 25 000 okay well and
how many credit cards are in that twelve
thousand dollar credit card debt I know
you said total but how many how many
separate are there I wanna there's a
bunch of some little ones there's some
little ones and one big one okay so it's
maybe four how is your uncle treating
you about that debt like what's his well
he's not talking to us oh gosh how long
has it been how long have you owed him
this money I mean the rent isn't even
that much so really we we like didn't
pay him for almost a year
why wasn't you read the book you know we
started paying him again like last month
he paid him we're budgeting for it now
it shouldn't be a problem at all from
now on
but now uh and he was he was nice to us
for a long time but just the last I
don't know how many months it's been
that he hasn't been talking to us and
specifically because everything correct
you guys are not having communication
because of the rent not because of
another issue no that's it okay what's
your communication been towards him I
know you said he's kind of been ugly
about it what's been your attitude
towards the debt throughout that year
that you weren't able to pay it
I mean we I always assumed oh next month
we'll figure it out oh this will I I
can't believe how much time went by yeah
and I was always saying to my husband I
was like we have to we it's not even
that much money we have to figure out
and it was always like well you tell me
how we really were lost until we read
the book yeah for sure
um Leanne have you guys I know you're
not speaking now but has there been any
conversation from your ends with just
kind of some humility and apology and
wanting to make rights with him has
there been that conversation
I I mean I I uh I do I tell him
what we're doing now and how I do tell
him he knows I'm that I'm sorry okay he
knows that I feel bad and that I wanted
us to do things together we usually do
yeah yeah you know dinners and whatever
and sure you know my kids love him so
much and they miss him and
it's hard oh absolutely well when a
relationship is fractured in the middle
of money stress as well I mean that adds
on and that it is it's it's
heartbreaking absolutely it's
interesting you know if it were me you
know in every other circumstance Rachel
I'm gonna go through and work the debt
snowball and pay things off in a
situation where there's family involved
maybe there's a relationship there it
could be worth going and paying that one
first eleven thousand what would you say
to that yeah you could
um and Leanna what I would even do if
you feel comfortable with it if you guys
want to do kind of the rigid way of the
debt snowball because I think for you
guys as a family your nuclear family
getting some quick wins of these like
kind of small credit card debts you know
that that she was saying getting kind of
some of those quick wins under your belt
will give you a boost of confidence and
there's even something Leanne I would
even write out all of your debts we say
to do that for that snowball smallest to
largest every credit card don't lump it
into one put do very specific credit
cards two different car payments this 11
000 loan put uh put payments below that
of minimum payments of what that's going
to be and then how much extra you guys
can throw at the debt and and build out
this plan and maybe if you communicate
that to him and say hey here's the time
frame important it by you know what are
we in July January so just say by August
or whatever it is we're going to start
paying on this
um and and it's going like here's our
plan here's what we're doing I think
just the communication part and showing
him actual numbers and dates absolutely
might help as well and an apology Leanne
I think too like just a humble Spirit
from you guys which I hear in you
um I think will be very helpful so I
hope that helps